riot accidentally did what the valerian
community has been asking four months
for them to do
and that is to nerf jet jets signature
dash was inadvertently slowed after the
game's latest patch and it started a
firestorm of discussion online
for better or worse the bug has been
fixed but
should it have stayed
[Music]
all right y'all before we get into the
video i gotta remind you hit the
subscribe button and the notification
bell and if you're like liz you look and
sound different than the entire rest of
this video tony has no idea what you're
talking about and tony would like you to
say that again to his face all right jet
means let me be the first to say that
this is a safe place for you to talk
about the nerve no one here is going to
judge you besides the entire comment
section but don't look down there they
think i look like faze baby bae anyway
which again what are you talking about
now that we're ready
jet was nerfed rather not nerfed but
bugged accidentally and the change acted
like a nerf if you're not sure what i'm
talking about patch 3.08 brought a
little surprise to the ballerina
community instead of jet quickly taking
out her weapon really quickly after her
dash or tailwind when the patch dropped
it took a little longer than normal now
this may not seem like the biggest deal
but in the case like jet it is the
smallest changes that can make the
biggest difference when discussing ko
and sky in a recent patch here's what
ryan had to say in some ways even the
smallest tweaks can result in big
differences when it comes to the impact
of flashes they're talking about sky and
ko and obviously jet doesn't have
flashes thank god
but it still applies to her
game-breaking ability especially as an
entry if jet cannot dash into her smoke
right away and fight
she's a sitting duck
jenny jenny so wait it pulled on my
dagger i keep forgetting that that thing
is bugged right now the dash
i got silver because of the bug dash
if that doesn't look weird to any of you
basically how that should have gone was
a quick entry and then a kill however
with the dash being bugged jet in this
case tens quickly dashes in and quickly
dies this was the accidental nerf that
came with patch 3.08 there were actual
jet nerfs in the previous patch they
nerfed the cloud burst and the knives
but not the dash which many players jet
mains insane people like saw as the real
balance issue in the agent the dash was
the linchpin for a lot of players the
accidental change which was a bug
not a nerf might be the best nerf we've
seen in the character's history this may
not seem like a huge deal and you may
find it funny to tell jetmains to go cry
about it you're not funny but let's
break this down first i'm going to let
hiko explain why jet in the right hands
has been such a good agent how is jack
going to entry like one of her main jobs
she can't
she can't be good at everything she
can't be good at entering opping
supporting throwing smokes
uh being able to have elevation changes
taking no fall damage ever being able to
block utility being able to block
flashes being able to throw one ways
being able to throw good entry smokes
being able to throw delay smokes being
able to throw a long smoke from a far
distance being able to smoke her feet
and hide in it she can't be good at
everything it's not fair as of the last
six months jett is the most picked agent
in the game in casual and ranked she is
the third most picked agent behind sage
and reina a bug like this is significant
not only because we had to find out the
hard way that it existed but whether we
like it or not the meta is partially
defined by jet it changes the way you
move how your team hits a sight the dash
is the single most important duelist
ability in the game however
ride games did not think the bug was too
severe in a tweet ray acknowledged the
bug and said the following jet's weapon
equipped out from her dash tailwind is
currently longer than intended and
updraft costs more than it should these
are bugs but not severe enough game
breaking competitive integrity to risk a
patch redeploy so it's possibly fix
won't go out until patch 3.09 regarding
the competitive integrity part you might
have been worried about the nalcq or
game changers emea or any other
competitions that would have been
affected by this bug but this is where
the valorant champions tour competition
rules come in most updated one i could
find for n a was challenger stage two
and the section we want to look at is
section 7.4 section 7.4 brings us the
rules about competitive patches if you
wonder why newer agents or your maps
don't get showcased in tournaments or
championships or whatever this is the
section you want to look at what we want
to look at is section 7.4.3
additional restrictions additional
restrictions example disabling certain
weapons may be added by riot
representatives at any time before or
during a match if there are known bugs
with any items agents skins or abilities
i checked out the other rule books for
other competitions and the wording is
the same this makes sense you shouldn't
ask your players to play with bugs that
isn't keeping up with the quote
competitive integrity specifically with
the n a lcq riot announced on october
7th that it would be played on patch
3.07 the bug was a part of patch 3.08 so
even if it was an issue ry could have
done something about it going as far as
to disable the agent that would have
been insane
some pros were fine with the nerf like
ten said in this tweet honestly if they
leave jet this way i don't mind seems
like a decent nerf to a character who is
picked almost all the time sabrosa
agreed saying that riot accidentally did
a good nerf for jet some pros like
shazam are doing a-okay with the nerve
one or two
calm down running upstairs
i think there's another
i think that that jet nerf redaction if
you're delayed to pull your gun out is
good
uh it makes the most sense
um
simply because like you'll see a jet
dash for a kill like or dash into a
smoke and there needs to be some sort of
buffer for the anchor holding aside or
something
to like have a chance against that play
but late on october 25th we got a tweet
from riot saying that they went ahead
and fixed the bugs there were some
immediate strong reactions but mostly it
seems like a mix between elation to the
return of the norm and just
really disappointed parent-type people
that's the best way i can describe it
there was a whole lot of shouting back
and forth between jet mains i wasn't
even a part of the conversation and i
felt threatened but next time you fight
can you all keep it down it was really
scary thank you so much but now that the
accidental nerf was taken away from us
it starts a conversation of whether or
not this was a blessing in disguise jet
stash has been updated four times by
riot in 1.0 riot made it so the dash
breaks cypher's trip after being
revealed in 1.11 you could no longer
dash in ropes or zip lines in 2.01 riot
fixed jet being able to trigger the
diffuse sound while dashing and finally
in 3.0 you could no longer break cyber's
trip while dashing jet's movement
specifically her dash are her signature
abilities it's what we know her to do
some say the accidental nerve completely
ruins jets and she now doesn't do what
she was originally designed to do if we
go back and look at the cinematic
trailer featuring phoenix her abilities
are literally the climax she spends most
of her time on screen running around and
dashing
yeah that's all donna i'm sorry no one
looks at jet and goes ah yes the smokes
are her pinnacle because they're not
they help for sure but it's her movement
that makes her no one moves like her so
should the nerf return or some version
of it or is touching jet anymore just
unfair hego put forth a suggestion he
thought would be a good nerf for jeff
who it was that said this on twitter but
i thought it was good where
you should uh
you should
not be able to dash before you get a
single kill like it should take two
kills to refresh your dash
but you should have to get a kill before
you can dash at least that way
you can't go stupid aggressive off the
rip because if you miss your shot you're
dead personally i think the original bug
slash nerf was unfair i agree with hiko
that i think jet should earn her dash
but once you make that happen
it isn't her signature ability anymore
so does the updraft become her signature
personally to me that just feels really
really weird do you give her like a sort
of astra suck that can move players like
like a sort of wind tunnel don't kill me
for using a gentian reference but you
know when you use your glider like
through those air things that move you
directionally like that but the enemy
won't have wings or fun i don't know
y'all i'm spitballing here i know that's
literally the dumbest thing i've ever
said on this channel but would you
completely change or add an ability i'm
not going to pretend to be like an
armchair expert and pretend i know
exactly what riot should do because i
don't i don't envy riot at all this is
an incredibly tricky spot you have given
your community a taste of a really good
nerf maybe is going as far to say fixing
the agent when you didn't mean to so
they know it's possible and they've
experienced it they liked it even loved
it it's like giving a toddler candy for
the first time they like it and they're
gonna expect more did i just compare
some of the valerian community to
toddlers
yes i did and with the way some of you
act in game i'm being extremely nice
anyways agents get patched all the time
i should know i literally spent part of
my day making an excel spreadsheet about
this so
maybe the next patch will bring a
surprise jet nerf that works for
everyone
wouldn't
it's okay